let's not turn to a very central
archetype in the psyche that of the
shadow the very name gives us a key to
what we're dealing with something in the
shadows something not quite in the light
something dark young says that and I
quote a closer examination of the dark
characteristics that is the
inferiorities constituting the shadow
reveals that they have an emotional
nature a kind of autonomy and
accordingly an obsessive or better
possessive quality this is from
collected works 9 2 paragraph 15 here we
have a very important idea about the
shadow it is highly emotionally loaded
with a life of its own at times we know
this because of what happens when we
begin to project the shadow it feels as
though it takes us over for a little
while try this exercise think of someone
of the same gender as you are someone
who you really dislike someone whose
habits and behaviors and attitudes are
quite disgusting to you someone who
really irritates you with their behavior
do you have that person in your mind now
list the qualities that they have that
you dislike they could be selfish or
gossipy or vindictive or always late the
person you just imagined is a real
living walking example of your shadow
and the qualities that you dislike about
them so much are your own qualities the
qualities of your shadow you have met
your shadow and it is you feeling a
little uncomfortable right now you and I
both know that you keep these qualities
to yourself very well hidden because if
people knew about your shadow side they
would never want to be around you young
said and I quote though the shadow is a
motif as well-known to mythology as
animus it represents first and foremost
the personal unconscious and its
contents can therefore be made conscious
without too much difficulty in this it
differs from anima and animus for
whereas the shadow can be seen and
recognized fairly easily the anima and
the animus are much farther away from
consciousness and in normal
circumstances are seldom if ever
realized with a little self-criticism
one can see through the shadow so far as
its nature is personal but when it
appears as an archetype one encounters
the same difficulties as with anima and
animus in other words it is quite within
the bounds of possibility for a man to
recognize that relatively evil side of
his nature but it is a rare and
shattering experience for him to gaze
into the face of absolute evil end quote
and again is from collected works 9 to
paragraph 19 now very important we can
think of the shadow as a complex recall
that complexes are the structures we
find within the personal unconscious I
will give greater detail about the
complexes in a later episode what is
useful for us now is that we can imagine
the complex to have three layers almost
like an onion the outer layer is the
personal shadow the next or middle layer
of the is the cultural shadow and the
central core is the archetype of the
shadow don't get confused by the fact
that we have an archetype at the center
of the complex I said that complexes
belong to the personal unconscious and
that archetypes belong to the collective
unconscious that's quite right so think
of the archetypal core of the complex as
simply being connected to an archetype
in the collective unconscious the first
layer the personal shadow is built up of
all of our personal experiences with the
darker side of life
as an infant we get early messages from
my parents that certain behaviors are
bad or naughty we try to stop these
behaviors but they all end up adding to
this first layer of the shadow complex
in the form of the personal shadow so
this layer is composed of all the nasty
or shameful parts of yourself that you
prefer no one else knows about your
spitefulness your bigotry your racism
your cruelty etc Jung said that the
shadow and I quote is the thing a person
has no wish to be
end quote that's from collected work 16
paragraph 470 the next or middle layer
is the cultural shadow think of how the
society you grew up in has a dark side a
side in which people were discriminated
against or persecuted or minorities were
hounded your cultural shadow if you are
in Canada like I am now is the manner in
which First Nations people have been
stripped of their land their language
and their culture another cultural
shadow on the island I live on Vancouver
Island is the wholesale decimation of
the natural world through clear cutting
of the forests so you can see that all
societies all cultures have a dark side
what is yours
the third or inner layer of the shadow
complex is the shadow archetype we know
this archetype well as we have seen the
archetypal image that derives from it in
a variety of places for example people
raised in the Christian religion know
that the devil is the embodiment of the
archetypal shadow we often tend to think
of historical figures as being the
embodiment of the archetypal shadow
people such as Hitler or Stalin if we
consider what these individuals did in
their time we can understand that they
enacted something beyond simple bigotry
something far more powerful and some
discrimination they enacted archetypal
forces of the shadow the Holocaust is an
horrific example of just how terrifying
the archetypal shadow can be what is
very important in our understanding of
the shadow is how well we actually know
it young was clear that we can never
eliminate the shadow but only come to
terms with it there is a very good
reason why we cannot eliminate the
shadow at the core of the shadow complex
is an archetype the archetype of the
shadow and we are not able to alter our
archetypes only to become more conscious
of their images and impact on the rest
of the psyche this means that we know
what our shadow qualities are cringe
whenever we think about these qualities
but endeavor not to enact them on others
as Luke Skywalker finds and Star Wars
the evil we see around us is within us
too
this means that if we are conscious of a
shadow we are also far less prone to
project the shadow onto others and even
better we have a reduced tendency to
enact the shadow to be conscious of the
shadow permits the projective capacity
of the unconscious I alluded to in the
earlier section of this episode